we have a saying you go pee in it to
change it and that is my word you need
to train it try and try never stop
trying because tried is what I did in my
life in my wor life
I keep trying because everybody think
I'm a no-good and I keep trying until I
become a too good
Great Britain was not great to his
common writer to people because we were
a different color
I came and I walk along the roof about
ten doors
everyone I knocked that didn't have a
card on it to say no gypsies no dogs no
Irish are no colored the lady aunt
Medora saw me and she didn't sell was it
a slum the door I said to myself I think
that's the norm here there was no rule
about discrimination and what you
shouldn't do
therefore they could do anything and get
away with it
when I try to buy my first horse get a
big crowd of white people's time to know
and I thought to come to welcome me in
there means no you know what they did
they said they didn't want me there I
said why did God made to color our three
color people why didn't just make
everybody block everybody white her
ruddy pink will have had this problem I
felt extremely degraded and thought what
what am I doing here and I think I just
gotta put up with it until something
comes comes along
we decide to fight anything that the
blackford who was involved to help them
out whilst we can obtained white labor
in this city we intend to go on engaging
white labor rather than colored labor in
a country ruled by Britain we drive our
buses we drive an aeroplane we drive on
the coppers was by trade so why is it in
England we can't do it oh we don't want
him on there that's the main reason
there ain't gonna be enough work for the
white lead alone the blacks they were
not 15 we said we gotta take it to the
other level we are going to for most
self in the group and stop the buses we
physically sit down in the road at the
time Arthur Scargill
was having the miners strike up north
and I we were having the straight down
here and at one state has said Arthur
Scargill Roy Hackett Antonia bad-news a
tree worst person in England
1965 Harwinton stood up in parliament
the battle against racialism here in
britain and he said as from today
any person discriminate against another
because of politics religion color creed
or disability you have committed a crime
punishable five months in prison or five
thousand or both and I cried I said
thank heavens for this I said we won
they never talk it in school that this
happened here and I said why are they
ashamed of what they done to us I talked
to two primary schools I always tell
them that we had to do that to bring you
up and never forget your roots
train is a great thing and if you've a
failed one try another time are trying
to improve what you fail on you know and
try them really because young people
today they are tomorrow's people and we
must try our best to make them be a good
tomorrow's people
you